the universes Beyond full outset was a
real home run so how is it they've
released one of the most mid secret
layers in a long time here's everything
you need to know for those new to Magic
thanks to the Fallout set secret lair is
an online magic the Gathering store run
by Wizards of the Coast that sells time
limited bundles they're on a website for
a set period of time until they sell out
most of the time the cards that are sold
are simply cards with new art like the
Sheldon Spellbook bundle other times
there are collaboration read skins like
the fortnite secret lair which features
magic cards that have been renamed and
feature new art and on rare occasions
there are exclusive cards like the
Doctor Who Regeneration bundle which
features five brand new to magic cards
based around new characters in the
latest season of Doctor Who for the
Fallout secret lir drop there are going
to be three time limited bundles that
start on April 8th there's the Vault boy
bundle the points of interest bundle and
the special bundle while no pricing has
been announced at the time of recording
of this video the bundles will likely
sell for
$29.99 for the non-foil versions and
$339.99 for the foil versions let's take
a closer look at each of the bundles to
start we have the special bundle which
has seven cards featuring fallout
shelter inspired artwork steel shaper
gift propaganda elixir of immortality
council's judgment idyllic shoor anger
and lightning bolt now this is probably
the most random mish mash mid tier of
Commander cards I've ever seen in a
secret layer bundle as far as value goes
the best three cards are idic shooter at
$6 propaganda at $5 and anger at $5
adding the total current market value of
these cards all together comes to about
$23 the foil bundle does get a little
small bonus
as the foil propaganda is a $15 card and
foil anger is $9 but this bundle feels
extremely me for Fallout fans you might
really enjoy the art on these cards in
which case go right ahead but for magic
players looking to level up their
Commander decks I can tell you right now
there are much better cards to be
playing up next we have the points of
interest bundle which features five
lands with Vault booy artwork command
Beacon Booka bog Fable passage
reflecting pool and reliquary Tower
again a pretty random assortments of
middling lands personally I've never
seen command Beacon being played in my
15 years of playing the game it's the
most expensive card in the bundle at
about $10 and is just about to get a
reprint in The Most Wanted commander
deck from Outlaws of Thunder Junction
bauka bog is a very Niche graveyard hate
card at just $1 however the cheapest for
foil pricing is $20 so keep that in mind
Fable passage is a land that is only
played in Niche landbased Commander
decks and can currently be picked up for
$6 in non-foil and $7 in foil reflecting
pool is a nice Commander land as it
generally Taps for any color of Mana you
need but it's not a hard requirement in
any deck and if needed you can pick up a
battle for Boulders gate version for
around $8 in foil and finally requery
Tower is just a bad $1 Commander card
that didn't need to be here again if you
like the art go for gold but I will be
skipping this one and finally we have
the Vault boy bundle which comes with
with a reskinned grand Arbiter Augustine
I sphere of resistance trinisphere and
winter orb out of the three bundles this
is by far the best one stack is one of
my favorite deck themes to play and all
four cards are excellent stack pieces in
terms of AR market value Grand arbiter's
cheapest printing is currently going for
about $4 and the foil is about five
sphere of resistance has only ever had
two printings its original Exodus
printing which is going for about $33
and the cadesh inventions Masterpiece
print which is going for about
$95 trinisphere has only been printed a
handful of times and its double master
reprint is currently going for about
$15 and finally there's winter orb which
hasn't seen a print since Eternal
Masters back in 2016 which is currently
going for about
$19 I would highly recommend picking up
this bundle as in terms of power level
of these cards included and the cohesion
of the cards it's topnotch now there are
three final Fallout cards we need to
talk about if you pick up the special or
points of interest bundle you get a
bonus full art waste land it's a land
that Taps for colorless mana and it only
sees play in alzi or artifact Commander
decks and if you pick up the Vault boy
bundle you get an old art codec Shredder
which sees next to no Commander play now
the Wizards team have mentioned that a
very small number of drops contain one
of the most powerful Mana rocks ever
printed manav Vol a one Mana artifact
that Taps for three
Mana we don't know the specific odds of
opening this card but it will no doubt
be as rare as the kaladesh inventions
manol that is currently going for about
$350
so what do you think of the drops will
you be picking any up as always if you
learned something be sure to like the
video and subscribe because if you don't
I'll blow up
Megaton thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one